Alors, quoi faire?
Olivier Bachand.
d'autres par nécessité.
Aller au centre-ville
en voiture et trouver
une case de stationnement,
c'
du combattant.
- Ça prend de la patience,
mais je finis toujours
par en trouver.
des moyens de transport
à l'extérieur de Montréal
qui pourraient nous rendre
jusqu'ici facilement aussi,
- Quand c'est pas un tournage,
c'est bibibixis, c'est plein
d'affaires, finalement,
c'est pas fait pour les autompm.
- 7 personnes sur 10 se
rendraient plus souvent au coeur
de la métropole si se déplacer
et se stationnern n n n n n n ne
commandé par la sociétédedede de
du centre-ville.
GLENN CASTANHEIRA, DG, société
- On aura jamais 250 000 places
de stationnement au rerere-
ville. Même, qu'on fasse sauter
le mont Royal, on ne pourrait
- L'arrondissement
Ville-Marie compte 7000 cases
de stationnement tarifées
- L'arrondissement
Ville-Marie compte 7000 éeéeéeés
en bordure de rue, mais il y
en aililililliers d'autres dans
les stationnements intérieurs.
Selon Glenn Castanheira, p p pr
indiquer où elles se trouventcet
toujours libres.
- Peu de gens savent
de stationnement hors rue au
centre-ville qui sont très,
très peu utilisées les soirs
et les fins de semaine.
Où sont-ils, ces stationnements-
Ils sont un peu partout au
centre-ville. Il y a des grands
stationnement institutionnels
comme la Place des Arts,
la Place Ville-Marie. et
privés et nous, on est
convaincus que la solutisesesese
par la mutualisation, c'est-à-
dire de mettre en commun
tous ces stationnemetetetetetet.
- L'Agence de mobilité durable
travaille ju mettre
au point une application
pour faciliter la vie
des autorererererererererererer.
Elle indiquera où ils sont
susc d d d d de trouver
du stationnement public
en bordure de rue, mais
intérieurs gérés par le privé.
LAURENT CHEVROT, DG,
- Elle va permettre d'avoir
l'information à destination
du stationnement, donc
peut-être pas totalement en
information pour les citoyens
automobilistes. Elle va aussi
donner une informaatatatatatata.
Donc quand ils sont disponibles,
comment on peut y accéder,
éventuellement même
- Mais pour y arriver,
il faudr d d d d d des ententes
avec les propriétaires
de ces stationnements et
partager l'information, ce quin.
- La littérature nous dit qu'à
peu près 30 % de la congestio
Amérique du Nord est liée d d dt
une place de stationnement.
Donc intervenir a a a a a a a at
à la fois sur la qualité
de vie des gens, mais aussi
sur les gaz à effet de serre-.
de l'application devrait voir
le jour en 2024.
bien des automobilistes vont
continuer de tourner en rond.ada